en otros vídeos hemos hablado de que
cada elemento está definido por el
número de protones que se encuentran en
su núcleo entonces por ejemplo cualquier
átomo con exactamente un protón en su
núcleo es por definición hidrógeno
cualquier átomo con 6 protones en su
núcleo es por definición carbono
cualquier átomo con 17 protones en su
núcleo es por definición cloro y estos
números que estoy señalando en la tabla
periódica de los elementos se conocen
como número atómico pero en realidad es
la cantidad de protones en el núcleo de
ese elemento y es lo que define qué
elemento es pero en este vídeo vamos a
ver esto con más detalle y nos daremos
cuenta de que podemos tener diferentes
versiones del mismo elemento y estas
versiones en química se conocen como
isótopos ahora cómo podemos tener
diferentes versiones del mismo elemento
siendo que el número de protones define
de qué elementos se trata bueno las
versiones o los diferentes isótopos van
a depender de la cantidad de neutrones
que tengan entonces por ejemplo hay dos
isótopos estables de cloro hay una
versión del cloro conocida como
35 permítanme escribirlo aquí cloro 35 a
menudo se escribe así cloro 35 y en esta
anotación de isótopos que vemos aquí
donde tenemos 35 en la esquina superior
izquierda s 35 es la suma de protones y
neutrones de esta versión este número 35
es el número de masa de este isótopo de
cloro entonces tiene un total de 35
protones y neutrones cuántos neutrones
tiene esta versión de cloro bueno va a
tener 17 protones 17 protones no sé por
qué estamos tratando con cloro entonces
cuántos neutrones tendrá pues 35 menos
17 es 18 18 neutrones y hay otra versión
de cloro que es estable y es el cloro 37
ahora cuántos protones tendrá bueno esa
es una pregunta capciosa por definición
es cloro tendrá 17 protones esto tendrá
17 protones pero cuántos neutrones
tendrá bueno los protones más los
neutrones son 37 por lo que 17 más 20
serán 30
por lo tanto serán 20 neutrones y esto
se escribe como cloro 37 entonces
podemos ver que estas son dos versiones
diferentes de cloro tienen el mismo
número de protones por lo que son cloro
pero diferente el número de neutrones
ahora pueden imaginar que estas
diferentes versiones tendrán diferentes
masas atómicas pero aquí en la tabla
periódica de los elementos sólo hay una
masa atómica promedio en la lista y la
palabra clave aquí es promedio es el
promedio ponderado de las masas de cloro
de los átomos de cloro estables que se
encuentran en la naturaleza entonces por
ejemplo en la naturaleza el 75 punto 77
por ciento del cloro encontrado es cloro
35 y luego el 24 punto 23 por ciento
restante del cloro encontrado es cloro
37 por lo que cuando calcula en esta
masa atómica promedio lo que hacen es
que toman o lo que ustedes tomarían si
ustedes lo estuvieran calculando sería
75 puntos 77% por la masa atómica del
cloro 35
más y sumamos el peso aquí que sería
24.23 por ciento por la masa atómica del
cloro 37 y si hiciéramos este cálculo
obtendríamos este número 35 punto 45
unidades de masa atómica unificadas
ahora como calculamos la masa atómica
del cloro 35 podríamos sentirnos
tentados a decir que son sólo 35
unidades de masa atómica unificadas y
estaríamos cerca porque la masa de un
protón está cerca a una unidad de masa
atómica unificada y la masa de un
neutrón está cerca a una unidad de masa
atómica unificada y debido a que los
electrones tienen una masa mucho mucho
mucho más pequeña incluso podríamos
considerarlos irrelevantes en términos
de masa atómica por lo que obtendríamos
una masa atómica cercana a 35 pero en
realidad resulta que es un poco
diferente porque no sólo las masas
atómicas de cada protón o neutrón
individual son un poco mayores a una
unidad de masa atómica unificada sino
que cuando se unen todos esos protones y
neutrones en un núcleo sus masas
combinadas son en realidad un poco
menores a sus más
las individuales si solo las sumamos y
eso se conoce como un defecto de masa
por lo que si realmente deseamos conocer
la masa atómica del cloro 35 la podemos
buscar en muchas tablas y veremos que en
realidad está ligeramente por debajo de
las 35 unidades de masa atómica
unificadas